it's january 2017 at the headquarters of
the african union
here in ethiopia an it engineer is
looking at the servers in this building
and something seems off the engineer
notices
that often in the middle of the night
these servers are
connecting to some server in shanghai
and uploading
emails and audio files
the african union headquarters was built
in 2012.
but it was not paid for by any african
nation
the impressive new headquarters of the
african union
entirely funded by the chinese
government
this building was a 200 million dollar
gift from the chinese government
it was designed and built by chinese
firms with chinese money
and yes the servers were installed by
chinese engineers
who it appears left an intentional
backdoor into the servers
so that they were easily accessible
the african union it team eventually
removed these chinese servers and
installed new ones
the chinese government literally offered
to install them for them but they
declined the local it people also swept
the building
and they found microphones embedded in
the furniture and in the walls the whole
building was bugged
and had been feeding audio and internal
emails
to china for like five years since the
building was built
china building a headquarters for the
african union and then
spying on it is a pretty good symbol of
what china is up to
in africa and that's what this video is
about it's about how a growing china has
rushed into africa
mainly by building a bunch of stuff
roads
trains dams mines ports these projects
are a part of china's growth as a
superpower
and it shows how this country is
projecting its power on the continent of
africa
but there are questions here over why
the headquarters of such an important
african organization
is entirely the work of chinese
construction
labor and money okay so there's this
very predictable thing that you see time
and time again as
countries get powerful as a country gets
rich they often start looking
outward both economically and militarily
let me explain what i mean here 50 years
ago china was
a very poor country with a huge
population but eventually they opened up
to the world they opened up their huge
population as a workforce for cheap
labor
and their economy exploded china's
agrarian urbanizing fast you betcha
but still agrarian most in terms of land
not population come on michael
no no you're wrong about this
so now china is a very rich country and
remember rich countries start looking
outward how can they project their power
connect with other countries
to continue their growth they do this
for a couple of reasons the first one is
the economic reason in the same way that
the u.s got really rich and prosperous
and started to look outward to china for
cheap labor
china also got rich and its labor
eventually got expensive wages went up
and china needed
its own option for cheap labor and new
growth opportunities
so they started pouring huge amounts of
money
like 300 billion dollars huge into
africa
[Music]
okay so that's the economic reason china
grows really fast their growth is
slowing down so they need
to invest in emerging economies is what
the economists will call it economies
that haven't
developed very quickly yet but that with
a little bit of investment
could start to grow untapped markets but
the economic explanation
is only half the story here
in china economics and government power
are not very separate so to understand
what china is really up to
you have to understand the geopolitical
motives and to do that
we've got to look at a map
here are all the countries that china
has projects in
and yes i've just highlighted every
single country on the african continent
i mean besides this one down here this
little tiny country of swaziland they're
the
one hold out on all of this these
projects range from
transportation projects like roads and
trains to
energy like oil and dams to real estate
projects like housing developments
and then mining for things like copper
you have everything from a shoe factory
in ethiopia to a six billion dollar
chinese financed dam in nigeria to a
massive suspension bridge
in mozambique the longest in africa
i mean these projects are everywhere
even here on this tiny island
off the coast where china has poured
millions of dollars to build
housing a stadium an auditorium a
library as well as their national
parliament
china built it all there are too many of
these projects to even count
and honestly if you take it as a whole a
lot of these projects
have been a major benefit and economic
stimulus
to these countries economies but why is
china doing this what are they up to
well in addition to all the economic
value of investing in emerging markets
china's president also claims that
they're doing this in the name of
cooperation and friendship
the african way let's dig into this and
actually
see what these projects look like and
how they are built and if it truly is
the african way whatever that means
okay so there's this really impressive
rail system that china built
in kenya it goes from nairobi to mombasa
in just under four hours which is faster
than any train in the united states
which let's be honest here
isn't really saying much because here in
the united states we don't really know
how to build trains anymore we used to
be really good at it now we're not it's
kind of a shame and
anyway look at this train in kenya
this railway system was a 3.6 billion
dollar project
the most expensive infrastructure
project since kenya's independence
and it was mostly entirely paid for by a
giant loan
from china's state-run bank so it was
financed by china designed by chinese
engineers and then built by chinese
construction firms that sent
chinese workers to hire locals and
manage the project
and now it's a chinese company that
actually runs the thing if you ride this
train
you're going to see all the safety
announcements and all of the
documentation
in chinese in mandarin it is very clear
who financed and built this thing it
looks like china just parachuted in and
plopped this thing down in kenya and now
kenya has billions of dollars of debt
that they have to pay back to china
eventually in fact
72 of all of kenya's debt
is owed to china and this railway was
meant to reduce congestion on the
highway that runs parallel to it but it
hasn't done that
in fact this railway cuts right through
like
these two national parks while the train
will offer passengers a view of a
lifetime while passing through the
national park
conservationists are concerned that this
construction will affect the ecosystem
and the wildlife that live here and it's
actually not doing what it said it was
going to do
so yes kenya has this big shiny railway
but it wasn't really solving
african issues in the african way
meanwhile the chinese construction
workers who came to build this thing
were caught treating the local workers
very poorly
making them sit at separate tables
during meal breaks
punishing them when they didn't complete
deadlines or take out the garbage on
time
that mixed with the fact that some of
these chinese workers were taking bribes
as a part of a huge corruption
scheme with this railway and it's clear
that this
project wasn't actually about supporting
the local environment it just left kenya
with a giant pile of debt
and a big shiny railway but listen
that's not always the case there are
tons of these projects and some of them
are truly helping the locals like this
big beautiful shiny road here in lesotho
this used to be a rough gravel road and
it is now a beautiful shiny road that is
helping the locals move around in their
country so it's definitely a mixed bag
and listen i get it china you want to
give a 5 billion
loan to nigeria to build a dam because
nigeria has 200
million people many of them young and
you want to
help them become a booming economy so
that you can get in on some of that
growth
oh and you love the fact that you don't
have to adhere to any environmental
standards while you're doing these
projects which i know you love
china i know it that's the business
rationale we're looking for new
economies to invest in
and be a part of their growth but if you
look a level deeper you won't just see
a bunch of investment projects you'll
see a bunch of
free gifts from china and i'm intrigued
by especially the political ones
like when china shows up and builds up
like a new parliament building which
they've done for
seven countries in africa or when china
offers 32 million free dollars to build
the new headquarters for ecowas which is
basically the
economic union in western africa they do
this for free we will build you a new
headquarters
well let me be clear there is no such
thing as a free
gift in international relations
everything has strings attached
so a major part of all of this
investment in africa
is china investing in its future as a
global superpower
who needs to have friends and has
historically not
had a lot of friends throughout the
world because the big boy united states
has been doing all the friending by
giving people stuff and making their
lives better so that they can be
allies so china is getting in on this
and china has used their checkbook
to make friends with literally every
single country
in africa of course besides swaziland
the teeny little country in the south
that has been the one country that has
held out on all of this in funneling all
of this money
into these countries china has been able
to get
all of these countries besides swaziland
to not recognize
taiwan anymore and to support china
instead
the tl dr on that is that you can't
support taiwan and china because they
both think that they're china so you
have to support one
or the other and so china has been
getting everyone to denounce
taiwan and say that they support china
that's a whole other thing i'm making
videos about that
suffice it to say that china has been
using its checkbook
to get all of these people to be their
friends it's sort of like
the the rich kid in middle school who
like brings you an mp3 player
because he wants you to be his friend
and you're like
sweet if you give me your mp3 player
i'll be your friend i grew up in
the early 2000s in my middle school
there were mp3 players
so sorry for the throwback but remember
when china built the african union
headquarters and then
bugged the entire building so that they
could spy on
the leaders and their emails and their
conversations that
is a perfect representation of the
strings that are usually attached to
these projects
but perhaps the less obvious but more
dangerous strings attached are the
deaths
[Music]
john adams said it best when he said
quote there are two ways to conquer and
enslave a country
one is by the sword and the other is by
debt it's a pretty intense quote but it
really applies here
so many of these projects have been paid
for by
chinese money through loans african
nations diving deep into debt
we all know that when you owe someone
money that person has a lot of power
over you
especially if you get to the point where
you can't pay them back and this isn't
just theoretical
a few years ago china helped sri lanka
build a port here in the southeastern
coast it was done with a chinese loan
with time sri lanka struggled to pay
back that loan
so in 2017 china swooped in and said
can't pay back your debt
no worries just lease us this port let
us have it for 99 years
and sri lanka is like that doesn't sound
great giving a piece of our sovereign
territory to
china which they could potentially use
for military but
we're in so much debt and they're
offering to relieve some of that debt if
we give them this port
okay so this port now belongs in part to
china
this sets a dangerous precedent that
could be applied
to many of these nations in africa who
have sunk themselves
deep into debt with china and may not be
able to pay it back in the future so
china is growing
and honestly behaving like any
superpower would
when they are growing this quickly i
mean
if we wanted to make a video about how
the u.s has projected power throughout
the years
it would be a lot worse of a video okay
so let's just make it clear that china's
a superpower they're doing their
superpower thing
this is very normal superpower behavior
doesn't make it right it just makes it
very normal and typical
china has taken a specific interest in
africa which has led to
countless infrastructure projects which
have been honestly an impressive site to
behold but has raised
questions of what are the actual motives
here they're not just business
and economic and the bigger question
that i want to keep an eye on going
forward
is how is all this debt going to play
out how will african nations who are so
deeply indebted to china
have to service that debt in the future
and what will happen
if they can't pay it back
[Music]
okay before you go i want to tell you
about the sponsor of today's video
expressvpn the way that i think about a
vpn is like
you can connect to the internet but you
can route it through a different country
so whatever site you're on
doesn't think you're in the country
you're in it thinks you're in a
different country
i use this all the time being able to
watch shows that are like only available
in the uk
and i can just connect through the uk
and suddenly i can watch a bunch of
shows that i can't watch when i'm
sitting in my house here in the united
states
the other thing i use expressvpn for is
usually when i'm traveling which i
haven't done in a while but i'm starting
to travel again and i'll be using
expressvpn
when i travel because like when i'm in
france and i want to
log into my email i don't want gmail to
freak out and be like you're in a
different country we think you're a
hacker
i route my connection through the united
states
which is like as easy as clicking one
button and now i can connect and
google is happy they think i'm in the
united states they don't make me do
like two-factor authentication and this
applies to all of my accounts it's
so nice it makes my travel so much
smoother and it does this all very
securely which i also like
feeling like i'm taking care of or my
connection is secure and private
and vpns they're great there's a link in
my description when you click that link
it helps support this channel but if you
go to that url you can find out how you
can get three months
for free of expressvpn so you can try it
out see if it's useful for you and then
continue if it is
three months for free go to the link in
my description to check that out to
learn more about it thank you expressvpn
for sponsoring this video
thank you all for being here and for
listening to this
story about china and africa i've wanted
to make it for a really long time and
honestly
i'm interested in making more videos
about china not just
about like chinese aggression and all of
that which i think is a very
american-centric way to think about
china
but like the real deal with china and
like what
china is actually up to it's a rising
power china is going to be a major part
of
our world for many years to come and
i really want to understand it as i
understand it i will be sharing that
all with you so have a good day and i
will see you very soon in the next video